♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SO EVERYTHING
CHANGED COMPLETELY, PARTICULARLY
IN THE BUSINESS WE ARE IN, THE
NEWS BUSINESS.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, COVERAGE STARTS
TO RESEMBLE RESEMBLE METAL LIDS.
YOU CAN PICK ANY NOUN AND SOME
WOULD DENOUNCING THAT AS RACIST,
PUNCTUALITY, RACIST!
ICE CREAM TRUCKS, AND AT
ONE POINT, SO CRAZY THAT THE
FEDS TOLD ABC NEWS THAT NATIONAL
PARKS WERE SOMEHOW RACIST.
>> NATIONAL PARK SERVICE WITH
PERSISTENCE WHITENESS OF 419
PARKS IS AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS.
THE AMERICAN WILDERNESS OF
PLAYGROUND FOR OLD AND YOUNG AND
OVERWHELMINGLY, WHITE.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AROUND, YOU
DON'T SEE PEOPLE YOU IDENTIFY
WITH.
YOU DON'T FEEL WELCOME.
YOU FEEL OUT OF PLACE.
YOU FEEL LITERALLY LIKE YOU ARE
AN OUTSIDER.
>> Tucker: SO HERE IS THE
GAME.
HERE IS HOW IT IS PLAYED.
THE SOUND LIKE COMPLAINTS, POOR
AND ME, BUT THEY ARE NOT
COMPLAINTS.
THEY ARE ATTACKED.
YES, THEY ARE AND THEY ARE
CONTINUING, EFFECT ACCELERATED
APPEAR AT "THE WASHINGTON POST"
HAS NOW DECIDED -- AND THIS IS A
REAL HEADLINE, IN FACT IT IS ONY
MONDAY BUT WE ARE STARTING WITHF
THE YEAR AND HERE IS THE QUOTE
"THE RACIST LEGACY MANY BIRDS
CARRY, BIRDS LIKE AVIATOR,
ANIMALS THAT FLY" IN THE POST A
SKETCH OF INNOCENT LOOKING FIRE
FENCE.
THAT BIRD MIGHT LOOK RED BUT
DEEP DOWN, "THE WASHINGTON POST"
TELLS US IT IS WHITE AS AN WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
BIRD BIGOTRY IS SYSTEMIC SO
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," OTHER
AVIATOR OPPRESSORS, THE SPARROW,
THE FRUIT DOVE AND THE AUDUBON
WARBLER.
THE WARBLER IS NAMED AFTER JOHN
JAMES AUDUBON, THE GUY WHO
LITERALLY WROTE THE BOOK ON
BIRDWATCHING.
HE HAS OF COURSE BEEN CANCELED
AS OPPRESSIVE.
HE THOUGHT ABOUT THINGS OTHER
THAN HIMSELF AND OBSERVE THE
NATURAL WORLD AND WROTE AND
PAINTED IT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH.
JUST CANCELING AUDUBON.
YOU CAN DO MORE THAN THAT X
KENNEDY TELLS US IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO OPPOSE BIRD RACISM.
WE MUST BE ACTIVELY ANTI-BIRD.
WE MUST DEFUND AND DISMANTLE ALL
SYSTEMS OF BIRD SUPREMACY
IMMEDIATELY OR ELSE WE ARE
IMPLICATED IN THOSE SYSTEMS.
WE NEED TO DECOLONIZE EVERY
BIRDS NEST UNTIL WE DO THE WORK
FROM A BIRD RACISM HAS A HIGH
GROUND.
IT IS LITERALLY DUMPING ON U